أخبار اللقاح كما لاحظت بشكل ملحوظ
في
غضون أيام قليلة ، اثنان ليس لقاح واحد بل
لقاحان يظهران فعالية ملحوظة
هنا
فقط لأجلك فرصة
للتحدث إلى الجمهور الأمريكي في الوقت الحالي ،
وبعضهم لديه أسئلة حول
لقاح يعتمد على  البيانات التي رأيتها ،
هل
ستأخذ أحد هذه اللقاحات
بنفسك وتوصي به لأفراد عائلتك ،
أنت تعلم أن الإجابة أه جيم هي نعم ،
أعني أنني سألقي نظرة
فاحصة في النهاية على البيانات كما هو الحال
في بقية  أن تكون الدولة قادرة
على الاستماع
إلى أشخاص مثلي ، لذا فإن ما يحتاجون إليه
لفهم
جيم هو أن العملية شفافة
ومستقلة يجب أن تثق بي في أن
مجلس مراقبة البيانات والأمان المستقل قد
نظر إلى تلك البيانات ورأى أن هذا
كان فعالاً  لقاح حتى
95 حدثًا 5 في اللقاح
90 في العلاج الوهمي 11 حدثًا شديدًا
صفرًا في اللقاح 11 في العلاج الوهمي
لفعالية 94.5 بالمائة
سيتم فحص هذه البيانات
بواسطة علم المهنة  ntists في FDA
سيتم تقديم هذه البيانات إلى
لجنة استشارية
ستنظر في الأمر في لجنة استشارية مستقلة وسيتمكن
الأشخاص مثلي وزملائي
العلماء من الوصول إلى البيانات
عندما يقولون إنها آمنة وفعالة
لمنحها  يمكنني أن أخبرك
جيم أنني سوف أتناول لقاحًا
وسأوصي عائلتي بأخذه أيضًا ،
وأطلب منك دائمًا
عندما تتاح لك الفرصة للتحدث
عن أفضل
الأخبار ، أفضل علامة على الأمل يمكنك تقديمها
للناس هنا الذين من المحتمل أن يكونوا الآن
يقاتلون  ما
هي أفضل كلمات الأمل التي يمكنك أن تقدمها
لهم الآن
بشكل جيد. أفضل كلمات الأمل هما
شيئان أحدهما يتعلق بالصحة
العامة والآخر مسألة علمية ، قضية الصحة العامة
هي ذلك النوع.  من
التدخلات التي ذكرتها للتو ،
يجب عليك أن
تفهم
أنها تعمل بالفعل ، نعلم أنه
كحقيقة علمية ، وبالتالي تنفيذها ،
لا يتعين عليك
إغلاق أي أعمال للقيام بذلك.
لا يزال
بإمكان الاقتصاد أن يمضي قدمًا بطريقة بطيئة
بطريقة حكيمة ،
والبقاء مفتوحًا ، افعل ذلك من وجهة نظر الصحة العامة ،
وثانيًا من وجهة نظر الصحة العامة ، قم
بإجراء مناقشة حول فائدة المخاطر
مع عائلتك حول
ما تريد القيام به مع
بعبارة أخرى ، قد تقول إنك تعلم
أن لدي أشخاصًا ضعفاء في الأسرة.
لدي أشخاص كبار السن لدي أشخاص يعانون من
ظروف أساسية ،
هل أرغب في الحصول على 10 15 20 شخصًا
يسافرون من أجزاء مختلفة
من البلاد ، وهذا
تقليد جميل
رائع نتمتع به  لديك جيم ولكن ربما يكون الوقت الآن
هو إجراء تقييم
لنسبة فائدة المخاطرة وربما
تعديل ما ستفعله من الآن
والشيء العلمي
هو أن هناك ضوءًا في نهاية
النفق المساعدة في الطريق
لذلك  لا ينبغي للقاح أن يجعلك
تتخذ قرارًا جيدًا ،
سنحصل على لقاح لذلك
لا يتعين علينا فعل أي شيء آخر ،
لا حقيقة أن لدينا لقاحًا قادمًا
يعني أنه يجب علينا مضاعفة الأمر
والتوقف عن العمل.  هنا لأن المساعدة في الطريق
والتي من شأنها أن تحفزنا
على القيام بعمل أفضل مع تدابير الصحة العامة